Sheridan we're here for your film tower
block and you do so many stunts in this
film don't you how did you prepare and
what was it like what I'd like to say I
went to the German stuff and I didn't so
hence why and one of the songs went
wrong on day one and I got punched in
the mouth and bottom a litte but other
than that we just saw got stuck in
really it was all filmed in a warehouse
so we're all in one location and we're
lucky the cast are brilliant and the
crew were amazing as well so we were all
like a little gang by the end of it and
we just got stuck here yeah holding guns
and it was brilliant fun now it's quite
a scary situation you're in in the film
isn't it you're in a tower block there's
somebody after you what would you do if
it was real life if it was me I would
run away crying I'm the biggest wimp
ever but yeah I think that's the point
of the story really it's like what would
you do in that situation fight or flight
and you're fighting for survival you
know so I'd like to think that I would
get a little fire in my belly and become
a bit kick ass but not as much as my
character to mean she's badass when it
all kicks off so but it was nice it's
nice to find my inner demon in strength
you did you take inspiration from for
the character I can say I'm like the
poor man's Angelina Jolie I'm never
gonna be if I had to go my own stunts at
least it no but ya know I wish I look
like a and do you think the movies got a
message to it as well because it kind of
had quite social film isn't it in that
sense yeah I think a lot of people will
relate to it and hopefully because it's
hopefully all appeal to a lot of age
groups but there is a good message in it
as well and I was just saying as well
that even though I've seen it numerous
times now I still jump and I know what's
going to happen so hopefully people will
be enjoying it for the kind of you know
tense of it does that mean that you
don't normally watch horror that it
frightens you too much I'm not good at
watching it on my own because I live on
my own with daughters and they bark at
the tiniest noise and I'm like what was
that so no I don't usually watch that
much horror
I caught the book now doing this I
really hope to do more horror but flood
and Goths you've got loads of other
stuff coming up in the meantime haven't
you got a little special something at
the old there
yes I start next week I'm very nervous
but very excited and completely
different again you know live lives and
testing course it's and being a lady
so yeah it's different again but I'm
really excited and of course you've also
been directed recently by Dustin Hoffman
haven't you in quarter what was that
like that was amazing he's an amazing
man Dustin Hoffman and Dame Maggie Smith
and Michael Gambon Tom Courtney I want
to curtsy on set every day it was
amazing and completely different again
so I was very honored I'm just really
grateful for all these opportunities at
the minute and that people are kind of
letting me have a go at different roles
you know it's really good for me and
lots of TV stuff coming up - you ought
to be programs haven't you tell us about
them yeah but the accused and Mrs Biggs
which I loved filming with that's five
episodes for ITV film that out in
Australia which was an amazing
experience and scapegoats and another
brilliant drama so it's just work cause
you filmed them all over there like a
year and a half and then it's just it's
amazing other awkward out one so it's a
bit strange at them and it's all a bit
surreal but but it's nice that we've
been seen in different roles and
hopefully we will all enjoy them and
what to be the what'll be next after a
header for you know there's a few things
in the pipeline and then I'm doing them
Midsummer Night's Dream that's next
summer with David Walliams and Michael
Grandage season plane - Tanya
so that will be fun what are you doing
that we're doing it at the no cows it's
the michael grandage season so that's
next year but yeah I could kick I can't
I have to think about the job in hand
otherwise I get a bit too nervous and
panicked so head of gobblers all that
I'm thinking about the meaning and
obviously tonight Clara block
you